a little light up
right
all right good morning everybody and
welcome to the waste Advisory Group
meeting being held in Gore today
the waste Advisory Group is the
governance group for wastenet and this
is the first occasion on which we have
live streamed our meetings and
openly invited members of the public who
might be interested to either be here
and present or to tune in to us
there's a number of reports of people
aren't aware of the activities of
wastenet a number of reports in our
agenda today and I invite you to go and
have a look at those if you want to see
some of the background
so I'll start asking for any apologies
please
thank you move those apologies be
accepted all those in favor say aye
carried now members who we have present
of just introduce them
um today we have Ian pottinger counselor
from invercargill uh Rob Scott mayor of
Southland Ben Bell mayor of Gore and
glennis Dixon who's the alternate to the
Gaul Representatives here today and
zooming in to us as well as councilor
Christine Menzies from Southland
District good morning to you all and
welcome we have here in the staff today
Jason Donegan
Aaron more more game is it mergan and
Grant Isaacs and Annie Benjamin and to
my left here
there is Rex Caple and to the staff
thank you for your input to the report
and look forward to your contributions
when we seek them here today thank you
are there any Declarations of council or
conflicts of interest
there appear to be none thank you
the first item is to confirm the minutes
of the waste Advisory Group held on the
30th of March are the any eras or
omissions that people have noted
there appear to be none
I do note that there is one item in the
agenda minutes that indicates that a
review brief lies upon the table and
that that will stay there in in that
status until otherwise required and it's
quite likely that there's some items
being dealt with today that will enable
us to go back to that at a meeting in
the near future so if I can have a move
out and a second of the minutes of the
meeting of the 30th of March be true and
accurate thank you Ian mover and uh
Mia Scott is second all those in favor
say aye
carried
item four which is on pages 4 to 82 of
our agenda
and I'll just go down to page four
is entitled the adoption of the terms of
reference and standing orders
and with Gore being the administrating
body
these standing orders traditionally are
those of the
um
Council of of their body and a copy has
been circulated are there any questions
arising in relation to the standing
orders
there appear to be none I do want to
raise
um item 19.3
in the agenda uh in the standing orders
19.3 provides a casting vote to the
chair
the purpose of this organization as a
governance body is to seek resolution of
issues by
consensus and I do wonder whether it's
appropriate to have that Clause there or
whether it's the wish that we actually
adopt the casting orders without that
any comment please
and use your little grid buttons
councilman
sorry just for clarification what is the
number and the membership of the wastek
group six six uh so as a tie break is it
would only be my suggestion given that
the Quorum is quite small
yes given given that um the um
casting vote can be used to proceed with
a new item rather than status quo and
consensus that's that's just my thought
um
yeah
I guess it's the other question with the
context of today having a counselor on
Zoom is whether we can actually whether
it's worth putting that change in so the
Quorum can be on Zoom as well to
minimize the chance of it having to
happen because given the distance that
we sometimes need to travel there may be
other times when people want me to be on
Zoom
and view of others
I I believe with the new climate change
adjustments to the acts that it allows
for crimes to be created via Zoom for
the next year I think we've got that
information at governance training
recently um so we can potentially add
that into our standing orders at least
for while that is present and then
essentially move it over I I would
concur with um with me and Scott on that
around
being able to vote from from Zoom or
create a quorum including those from
Zoom councilor posinger your view
uh yeah I think
the zoom idea is a good one because of
that and that geographical
hindrance sometimes and the other one
regarding the uh deciding revoke by the
chair
um look we've got two from ICC we've got
two from Gore and two from SDC now I
would expect that
the the votes would be according to the
councils
preference and and and what would be
best for that Council
so it would either be poor too six nil
or you know I can't you know like if
there's a if a council splits its vote
and and for example Barry
um they was Voting against what I would
vote I'd say we have an issue in our own
Council and and so I've got no problem
with those standing orders I see where
you're coming from and if we want to get
rid of it we can do it now well I think
the mood of the meeting is leave the
standing orders one as it is but to have
an addition to standing orders that
makes that adds people coming in by
remote connection as part of the Quorum
so if I could have that an emotion from
someone please
right so the motion would then read that
the gore District Council standing
orders be adopted for the waste Advisory
Group with the exception that in clause
and someone will need to find the with
the exception that for the purpose of a
quorum
person's connecting remotely shall shall
be counted
and that was moved by councilor
passenger I believe and seconded by
Mayor Scott
all those in favor say aye
carried
now in terms given given that we've
adopted the standing orders my approach
to cheering my preference is that when
we have an item to see questions
from members
then to have a discussion and followed
by a motion
unless and that's because most of the
items that come before us are not
controversial but I'm happy to deviate
from that process where where members
see that as desirable
so we will move on to count to item five
which is the meeting schedule for 2023
and the intent there is that we hold our
meetings
um roughly six weekly and that uh
they're rotated amongst the different
councils
um
if there's no questions I'll ask for
someone to move the meeting schedule for
the remainder of 2023 be adopted
I'm reminded again that Monday is the
11th of December not the 13th
that's what happens when someone copies
from some what someone else has written
so the the motion was moved by councilor
pottinger and seconded by mere Bell
all those in favor say aye
carried
we then move on to item six which is the
waste Advisory Group update presentation
which starts at page 83 of our agenda
which is a very informative description
of the activities other than the
physical collection of waste of the
activities are there any questions that
arise from that report
talk about the strategy policy
the yes
so that's the the reports on page is 83
to 95 and I'll just zoom across to it
just be with me
so it's a presentation of what I
described as as slides
um giving
details of what's in the legislation you
know existing goals action plans and
updates in terms of activities relating
to education communication and potential
projects
councilor postinger I think I think the
visit to the landfill the other day was
invaluable I think for everyone I think
everyone gained sort of a quite a fresh
understanding of what's happening and so
I'd like to bring up one of the topics
that was mentioned uh while we were
standing with that wonderful view
about the
residential food scrap collection by
2030 now
basically they told us that this is
an ineffectual really it's it's a blip
yeah if I can just just sorry to
interrupt but I think that discussion
might be better under the overview okay
um because the
um New Zealand waste strategy and
um
on page 99 of the agenda has makes
reference to that 2030 okay and that's
probably a better place no sounds good
so any other questions in relation to
the report on the update
there appear to be none is there any
discussion arising from it
appears to be none so the the motion
that we have is the information be
received can I have a mover and a second
it please
so that that will be Mayor Scott and
moving and councilor passenger seconding
all those in favor say aye uh carried
item seven is the waste net overview and
starts at page 96 of the agenda
and
uh
is a detailed report covering a number
of matters do members have any questions
and I'll take questions and then I think
we will go through it part by part it
seems to be divided into logical
sections so are there any questions of
Staff please
there appear to be none however
Christine has a question
cancel
it means it
you appear to be on mute
um
they know about identifying vulnerable
landfills
in my question are around it has that
been identified as part of this group
is there a staff member who can help
respond to that please
make sure
hasn't been turned on
thank you uh chair
um can I just uh clarify is that a
question with regard to whether or not
the ab lime landfill is a vulnerable
landfill is that the question
no it's not I was just wondering about
vulnerable landfills and and each of the
council areas of evini
um but it may not perform part of the
discussion of the past and if this group
is just looking at AV line then that's
fine as well
uh as far as I'm aware uh the discussion
of vulnerable landfills is something
that's been managed individually by each
Council as opposed to being managed as a
joint activity by waste net
are there any other questions
all right I will open it up for
discussion then
um part one of the report just deals
with an overview
um of
um uh wastenet and that's page 97 is
there any comment uh arising from that
appears not part two
um deals with the business plan
and I'll start by on page
um
99 it does make reference to the New
Zealand waste strategy and also
the in relation to the fourth one two
three
fourth bullet point on on that page
counselor pottinger making reference to
food scraps collection services to all
urban areas by 2030 so this is the time
to speak to that
look there's a couple of things and and
I'll start with the first one and that
is what they're trying to achieve and
reduce carbon emissions and if we
well what we heard at the landfill is
that our food scraps make up point
of something up there and like it's
inventissimo uh the cost of diverting
food scraps you'd have to have a
dedicated bin collection system and uh
some sort of
organic composting thing that we would
have to contract in to get done and the
cost and what you achieve
I believe is this is really just been
triggered by a real feel-good thing and
there's no not one practical element to
it
considering that if you if you to a
survey of residents a lot of them well
I'm using I'll use my house for example
all kitchen scraps go to our composting
bin they already do that and
um
I think the it's it's the least
by far the least important thing that we
need to do I mean product stewardship
they keep bringing this up and I've been
doing this for 12 years and and no one
seems to want to take ownership of it
and that's where if you sell something
if whatever product you sell you need to
take responsibility for
for its either disposal or recycling or
something like that those sort of things
are more key than the foods the food
scrap one that's so low on the agenda
for me
and Scott
yeah that's that was quite some clear to
me at that visit to the landfill the
sort of misalignment between the way the
government legislation is going and the
actual needs on the ground and
I think for us to be focusing on those
food scraps and putting a hold of
potential investment into when there are
other potentially more localized
Solutions like I know out in Seattle for
argument's sake but a community garden
there that would quite happily do the
composting and all of that there so I'd
have to be sort of standing on the toes
of potentially
a solution that could be dealt with
locally and not needing that whole
connection and
um but but also noting the fact that the
landfall would quite happily take more
food scraps for the nature of your
operation
so yeah I think we've got to almost play
a bit of an advocacy role in that thing
and looking more at the E-Waste which
was quite obvious to me as a severe
problem there with those lithium
batteries and the potential for fire and
all that kind of risk there as well I
think it's um that should be the focus
councilman Menzies
probably consistent with others more
than a thousand is it
yes
councilor Dixon
thank you Mr chair just wondering if the
I don't know if you spoke about this at
the um when you went to a b lime but the
methane that's given off by food scrapes
seems to be an issue more than the
actual
waste of food scrapes and the small
amount that it is but it's amount of
methane that's given off from food
scrapes and in this case ABIA lime
extracts the methane and other gases
that are coming off the landfill and
what they highlighted was the food
scripts going into the landfall is an
essential component to get an efficient
guess
um
volume out of the the whole area and
I I agree with the other speakers that
where there is a Modern Landfill that's
extracting the gas the one size fit all
that has been promoted by government is
not suitable and I think we're all of a
like-mind in terms of this this is a
case where
um
I believe that waste net should be
adopting a role advocating for sensible
application of it and similar to other
standards and the like the government
issues it says if you do this fine if
you don't then you must do this so in
the case of landfills that are
extracting the gases and doing so in an
efficient manner continue to do so if
you're not doing that then you need to
think about how you're going to process
your food food scraps and if someone
would like to when we get to the Motions
give some thought as to how we can wear
the motion that that picks that up that
highlights that wasting should be having
an efficacy role in these situations we
can talk about it in a couple of minutes
just something to add to that is it the
cost of the food scrapes to a b lime and
how would we get them there if we did
collect them I mean it's
if we take the food scripts out of our
waste apparently it's a lot less but
Jason speaks well it ends up in the same
place it's going there now as part of
the general waste yes I understand that
but that's a cost isn't it and it's
going to rise so but if we were to take
the foods out yes yes so if we were to
take the food scraps out would it be
cheaper yes
sorry me Bell
I guess it raises a good point it was
swirling around my head is in their
advocacy role is there a conversation
needing to be had that if we're going
along the lines and we want to put food
waste into landfill because we know it's
being collected is there a a
exception to the levy that we have to
pay um and how does that all get ironed
out with the likes of central government
as to that portion of the weight we
should have to pay for
good point Thank You councilor passenger
I'm just speaking to that
um if we took the food scraps out of our
waste and it was basically inert product
going to the landfill they would still
charge us the emission training thing
there is nothing yeah the point is if
the food scraps are taken out and sent
separately
would the government change the rules
that you didn't have to pay no they
would not
we need to persuade them otherwise no
you are fixed so there is no point in
altering your composition and for an a
grade Land Fill to work as a proper
bioreactor which which they
right
um the small amount of food waste is
there
um yeah
okay
yeah
um just another thing to add further
counselor Dixon was that the uh the more
Organics they get and the more methane
they produce the less coal they need for
their burn on their drying their lime
so there's a there's another
environmental incentive there
and sorry just for my my clarification
too not being present at that meeting so
we're talking a lot about food scraps
here was the same talked about for
Organics generally so green waste in
those parts as well it leads on to that
doesn't it so I think what we've
highlighted here is that there's a
conversation we can usually usefully
have
in our own context
and and from that to help inform us to
follow through uh with government a
number of issues
so thank you for that conversation
um finally yeah
if
so
well if you can put it on because it's
been live streaming okay if they don't
have a
or are seeking more work to do at some
stage we could
um do an exercise
where and I know that our subcontractor
and invercargill bond contracts have
looked at the the feasibility of a
composting site and then we'd have to
look at the collection
separately of food waste and if we
wanted to do that whole exercise but I
think
staff have gone Along on their plate at
the moment they're not even worry about
looking at that
um like the the about to do it in
Dunedin or I think they are doing it and
what it does it means if you do take the
foods waste out and they're a separate
small bin for it it means that your
general waistband is collected less
often so it goes down to fortnightly
because it's not sitting there running
away so I think the business case needs
to be looked at you know and then
compared to what we've talked about but
if it says 2030 there maybe we need to
prioritize it back a wee bit that it's
not on the radar at the moment and it
may well be that it can be picked up as
a project for which we can get funding
from I mean we can learn from other
councils yes yes
okay well it's highlighted as an issue I
think to be reported back
um yeah sorry just one valid point and
that's that the team have already put
forward a proposal for funding around a
a business case which we think that
there would be a strong chance of
receiving
um where that would be funded at 75 by
central government and they've advised
us that if we wanted to include glass as
part of that Organics business case that
they were they're happy also to fund
that expansion they wouldn't fund a
glass only though at this stage right
thank you all right so we'll move on to
the other parts in in that report at
page 101 is the objectives
is there any comment required people
want to make in terms of the short-term
long-term objectives of our work
appears not I do know if on page 103
my name continues to be spelled
incorrectly
um
okay page 104 refers to the education
Communications strategy
um in any comments uh with regard to
that please
and that goes through to page 109.
um it appears that that it sets out a
really all a comprehensive list of
activities that are taking place and
have been for for a amount of time
rather than anything new that's there
there appears to be no comment uh page
109 part 4 deals with the solid waste by
law now the report based on a comment
that I made says that none of the
councils actually have a solid base
bylaw the gore District Council does
have one and was updated uh in 2019 it
is of the old tradition I'll come to you
in a moment it is of the old um uh style
and there's probably a desirability
um that it be updated Erin you had a
comment I just wanted to clarify it
speaks to there not being a common bylaw
across all three councils we are aware
that there are individual bylaws right
so I see it as a task for
the
staff that support
our work to address that
the um then there's a series of
appendices in
um from page 110 onwards or for several
pages of the work that's happening in
schools is there any comment in relation
to that
which I'm sure all support
councilor posinger
I guess we're focusing on
education at schools but
um we really well for ICC we need to
educate our general public because they
have no idea
uh what the throw and what then and it
needs to happen immediately
so we would you know we we need an
immediate curbside or household
education process and now that the
government have highlighted
Plastics one two and five cardboard and
whatever
then we've got a very very simple sheet
for stuff to send out to people and then
after a few months of Education we do
enforcement
and there we go
and and to achieve enforcement we need a
bylaw
yeah
and Lisa comes under the health
regulations which are difficult to
enforce but it does reinforce the
message in terms of the vital
I think we currently errand we currently
have the ability to
cancel a service we have a I thought we
had a strike system so that was up
around how did that operate
there's a couple of pieces to that one
where you have the ability to stick a
people's bins so they know that they've
done the wrong thing what we don't have
the ability to do to my understanding is
to legally remove somebody's service and
that's because it's a service that they
are paying to receive I'm aware that
some other councils have been receiving
some legal advice in this space that
even with a bylaw there's been a
question around whether you can legally
remove that service or not it's
something that we need to take our own
independent legal advice as wastenet as
to whether we could go to that extent
most other councils that I'm aware of
have shied away from doing it because of
that legal question
it is an issue that I looked at about
two years ago and and reached the view
that with the wording of the legislation
at present it is doubtful that the
service can be withdrawn
um but under our bylaw there is the
opportunity of issuing fines
Grant is in Southland District we sort
of use the three strikes near out
probably more rural than our sort of
urban areas and to be fair we wouldn't
go any further than that at the moment
we haven't struck and struck anybody out
because generally after the second time
they sort of get it and come on board
thankfully and it's um yeah we haven't
we haven't tested any anything legally
yet and probably wouldn't without any
further advice I do Wonder then as part
of the Motions that we put forward
whether there should be reference to
proceeding with
preparation of a bylaw that is able to
be as standard bylaw across all three
councils
from a staff point of view do we need
that as a resolution
what what's currently in the budget I
guess provides for that that program of
work over the next 12 months
um what is Staff we've proposed is that
we need to obviously prioritize what
needs to be done and we do believe that
that priority should start with the
education piece and we want to get that
up and running and out before we start
going down the bylaw path just from a
resource perspective so at the moment we
do have some money in to start the bylaw
work in the upcoming Financial year but
not until the new calendar year we
wanted to focus on the remainder of the
calendar year of getting that education
out and humming
notwithstanding in the meantime Gore has
its by law in place and is able to to do
things all right any other comment from
that uh councilor Dixon
um thank you Mr chair just regarding the
education of our students it would be
really nice to include in that being
careful about where they deposit rubbish
because I'd walk around town a lot and I
can fill up huge rubbish bags sort of
KFC McDonald's pizza boxes a drink I
mean that needs to be included in the
education at school is what's happening
to your brother when you throw it out on
the street and not just young people
either but also I was wondering if
there's some way that we could
um Target those fast food places to say
you know you need to stop creating this
rubbish that's being thrown all around
our town because it is quite prevalent
it's just a thought
councilor possinger
you've just touched on product
stewardship and the failing of all
governments it doesn't matter which
color it is have failed to to do that
just getting back to education we've you
touched briefly cheer on E-Waste and on
the batteries now is that something
we're going to proactively
educate people on to try and but do we
have a do we have an alternative
deposits now I see it as part of the
education program maybe staff can
comment and confirm where are they going
to go when you don't put them in the red
bin
where do you take them to yes so there
is money allocated in the budget
specifically around E-Waste um
batteries yeah
it would form part of that yeah and
that's it for that's for work to be done
in the upcoming 12 months absolutely and
a depository for it
okay so we'll move on to the next
section which is the page 113 the waste
net Southland joint Waste Management
agreement and this has previously been
discussed that that was an agreement
that data back to 2011 and the um
uh the chief executive of the gore
Council had indicated that he was
willing to lead a team to update that
and report back to us so that will be
part of the work program going forward
but are there any comments other than
recognizing that that people wish to
make
all right yeah it counts apart yeah I
said Nate's bank I see Moses signatures
at the bottom there so it goes back a
wee while
um and I think it needs to obviously
hopefully we can come to an agreement uh
with
with Gore's
um
what they want to do with Recycling and
you know sort of move forward to a
flexible obviously things change
um
yeah it'd be interesting to see what can
be brought to us
and Gore at present has a report sitting
on the table I believe near Bell in
relation to recycling
um and and further reports that are
coming to council so it's something
that's actively been looked at any other
comment to add mayor Bell
no I think uh the upcoming agenda
tomorrow has costings for us but um yeah
it's I think we're all trying to come
with a bit of a unified approach
um to this issue but it's definitely
active in our nice fear
thank you
moving on then to page sorry
um
just to touch on the I guess some
urgency for a bylaw is that
um
we get we're talking about serious
contamination of recyclables arriving at
invercargill transfer station at the
recycling station they get dumped on a
concrete pad
and by the contract they have with us
they can go this is crap this is rubbish
we're not accepting it we can't recycle
it it's got living things in it you know
so
it'll get scooped up
and goes to the transfer station and is
charged out at the high rate of
wastegate to to the landfill now
if we don't have the ability to to stop
people putting this rubbish in there on
it you know we really need to otherwise
we're just going to pay for it actually
you've got 98 of the population
subsidizing two percent who don't really
give a crap yeah so I just like some
teeth somehow
that we can actually stop a service
me Scott
thanks Mr G just a question on the
agreement just I didn't see anything in
there about the reserve balances and
potential if any of the councils were to
withdraw from the contract what happens
to those Reserve balances and whether
they stay with waste that or get
apportioned out if this agreement
dissolves or anything like that was
there anything in there covering those
what is in there from memory relates to
the spending of of monies and and it's
as if there's agreement and it's for the
purpose of waste net activities that can
be funded if there's not agreement then
it is apportioned to the various
councils based on population size
I can't recall seeing anything in the
agreement that
sets in place the framework that have
won Council was to pull out what what
happens to theoretically their share I
would imagine in terms of agreement as
worded there would need to be in
negotiation I could assure the public
however that I believe there is no
intent of any of the councils to pull
out a waste net in the foreseeable
future
but it may be something that can be
noted and if appropriate added to the
agreement yeah certainly wasn't
highlighting that intent at all that um
just whether we need to have something
in that agreement just to you cover your
worst case scenario in the agreement so
it's there before you need it it's just
my um good point I'm sure it's noted
um page
um yeah then page uh it says one two
four
um
I'll just
say the agreement is signed and then
there was the
um
next item that comes up here so that
takes us to the end of their document so
having received those comments we've got
three motions already on the table uh in
terms of the report being received a
business plan be endorsed and that the
waste minimization education Community
communication strategy be endorsed
someone I can wish to move a fourth item
in relation to food waste and an
advocacy role
so uh
um
Mia Scott you're nodding your head or
Glenn
counselor Menzies did you have your hand
up
um
and actually I don't know we have in
terms of reference and we just got the
event
is
it's referred to as terms of reference
and agreement
can we take out the word consideration
and and just say that waste net add to
its role or add an efficacy role to its
activities
because I think there's agreement around
the table that we should be and that can
be formally recognized in in the
document but would then give us the um
ability to move forward and do some
advocacy work prior to that document
being completed
so
um comment from staff wanting to give
some direction are you
I just wanted to clarify that around the
wastenet agreement there's not currently
money in the budget for a review in the
next 12 months and it was although it's
something that staff recognized would be
nice to tidy up with the other
priorities that we felt were being
wanted to be achieved we had dropped
that one lower down the list at this
stage yes and that's something we need
to discuss later yes yes I um
so that's that's why if if we have a
motion that gives us that authority to
Advocate at this stage now
um has someone written that down please
in terms of where it is at
no no so my my understanding is and and
uh councilor Menzies helped me through
um that
um waste net or sorry or the waste
Advisory Group
um add an advocacy role to its
activities
um
and that's probably in a simple term
yes
thank you so can I have a remover and a
second or for those four motions please
Yeah question
is regarding the the communication
education what time frame do we expect
to see that happening
um well I think that's a discussion we
can have in detail when we're looking at
the budget
okay it's an ongoing activity there
um and I think what you're saying is you
want to see it boxed it a bit so let's
talk about it I think it's I think it's
ongoing because it's not happening if
you if you go back to the comments of
the previous chair
in in the uh it says that waste Nets and
holding pattern I just want waste net to
get out of its holding pattern yeah we
all do and land you know
um
so yeah that's what I'm sort of hinting
towards yeah so um we do need to have a
discussion in terms of priorities and
um as part of the budget and the um uh
part of the meeting where the public
won't be present
um so can I have a mover and a second
for the four motions please so that Mia
Scott moved and seconded by councilor
pottinger all those in favor say aye I
carried
move on to item eight which is the waste
net Services overview starting at page
139 of the agenda and so this just is an
overview of the waste net activities
um any questions arising from that
please
I have to say it was a nice clearly
worded report that set out the
activities very well is there any
discussion on that report
appears not the um
report or there's two recommendations
on this that the report be received and
that the waste Advisory Group note
wasting its role in the management and
the safe efficient and efficient way
Services yes you've got a comment have
you all yeah there's it's it's
in the background and if you look at
page 139 it's got waste
is an extremely complex politically
it tooks now now I think look from 12
years experience
I think by making it complex we've
actually made it difficult for us to do
anything I think it's actually quite
simple
we picked you know we throw stuff on a
bin we pick it up and we put it
somewhere
um I think I think we open ourselves to
finding excuses not to do things rather
than move forward so like I just
I actually don't believe it is complex
at all
so
that's my comment on it and and if you
take that complex approach you'll tend
to find more excuses than Solutions
so you're adopting a kiss approach
keep it simple
it is here's something something like
that but it just through my experience I
was on night nine years on waste net and
yeah
nothing seemed to happen and it was
because we tended
things got made too hard
so I guess that's what I'm trying to
bring forward me and Scott
thanks Mr I'm just a question probably
for staff but just on page 140 there
where we're talking about the existing
contracts with the bond contractors for
the um collection
does adding extra bins for glass how
does that work with an existing contract
that's an agreement to 27 is there
flexibility and that if we do decide to
go down that road for whatever reason
that it can actually be done
so when the original contract was
entered into with Bond there were a
number of possible changes that may come
in in the future that were spoken about
at that time
I'd expect Bond um you know the
discussions we've had with them to date
around expanding or changing the
services they've been very open to doing
um I think the the piece that we'll need
to work through is particularly other
councils have had a little bit of an
easier go of introducing things like
glass collection where they've had spare
collection days and therefore not
needing to have more trucks and more
drivers at this stage we don't have that
easy spare space so we are going to have
to work closely with the contractor to
see what we can do smartly around that
yeah I think given the distances that
they have to travel as well around here
geography at some yeah that's it feeds
into it
thank you in any other comment
councilor Menzies
yes
around items like
are there issues around health and
safety that we need to tend to
immediately the religious requirements
around it
the staff assist please
[Music]
risk no not not that we've identified in
terms of that we're aware of something
happening at the landfill that we're
particularly concerned about more of the
issue is simply around the fact that a b
lime don't form a traditional contract
relationship with us whereby we pay them
for a service and they need to deliver
that otherwise essentially that service
doesn't exist a b lime Ira
independent commercial landfill and we
pay them for the ability to access this
service perhaps not dissimilarly to the
way you would pay a power company for
access to their power service
as a result AV lime they do have some
requirements in the contract around what
they would provide us for health and
safety reporting Etc but there there is
some discussions at the moment around
what we need to receive from them to
discharge our pcbu obligations and in
fact whether we are a pcbu for the
landfill at all that we need to work
through
and and for the benefit of those who
don't use these technical terms all the
time a pcbu a person conducting a
business undertaking which essentially
is a person who other than the uh
individual creating the service uh is
somebody who is responsible for their
health and safety of the service
and whether or not waste net holds that
responsibility
following on from that so how come
London landfill Services Under
challenges highlights the health and
safety but under Recycling services that
doesn't highlight the health and safety
for the recycling plant and there's
conveyor belts with moving bits and all
sorts of stuff there
as simply a difference of perspective
between the contractors around how they
need to provide reporting to us
and the same with Bond contracts and the
trucks driving around picking Out
wheelie bins and bond is a little bit
different because Bond operate out of
our own
transfer stations for each of the
respective councils
so they're not operated out of a private
facility
okay so the health and safety
requirements out on the street driving
around with yeah so this this is around
the level of reporting being uh received
and we receive reporting from bonds we
receive reporting from uh from recycled
South uh while a b lime have advised is
that they their legal team believe that
they have different reporting
obligations to what the other
contractors do and so we're just working
through that to make sure that we don't
leave waste in a vulnerable position
me and Scott
just a quick comment around West cycle
South I believe that um that's not
actually part of a wastement
activities at the moment so that
probably doesn't apply to to this this
group it's probably more so with the
individual councils that are
working with it as I understand it thank
you
all right is it appropriate now to put
those two motions forward if I can ever
move her in a second dip please
so um Mia Scott and second
by councilor posinger
all those in favor say aye aye
carried
that brings us to the end of the public
part of the meeting thank you for
participation we will take a brief
recess
before conducting the next part of the
meeting and that's in relation to
financial reports and budgets for the
organization and we will be doing that
because it involves commercial
operations that are sensitive